joe biden's supreme court nominee
katanji jackson has been in confirmation
hearings for three days during which
time she has refused to say when she
thinks life begins
she pled ignorance when she was asked
what a woman is
and she defended her extremely light
sentencing record for pedophiles
it has not been a great first week for
her and democrats are now scrambling to
stop the bleeding as the chairman of the
proceedings dick durbin demonstrated
yesterday when he refused to let the
judge
answer a simple question from ted cruz
your child pornography possession crime
was egregious in the court's view okay
so this is a bad one if you're actually
sentencing defendants you said this was
egregious what did you set in stuart for
the guidelines said 97 121 months
prosecutor said 97 months you said it's
agreed just six thousand seven hundred
images
you come in with fifty-seven
in the stewart case do you want to
address that
does she want to address that
no she does not want to address that
judge jackson had already lost her
temper as republicans focused in on her
strange record of letting pedophiles off
the hook but she didn't even have the
chance to address the record by
responding to cruz's question because
dick durbin started talking over both
her and cruz and did everything that he
could to move on
you're not recognized senator senator
you don't want her to answer that
question
you wouldn't allow her mr chairman she
may answer the question i've asked her
why she sat in stewart
i'm senator by two minutes why she said
because you've interrupted me for two
minutes mr chairman will you allow her
to answer the question or do you not
want the american people to hear
why with someone she described as an
egregious point senator where you get a
little bit chairman durbin will you
allow her to answer the question you
want to allow her name i i will happily
allow her to why are you not allowing
her to answer the question there's not
another senator here who has not allowed
her to answer the question i'm not
asking another question but allow her to
answer the question chairman durbin
thank you chairman why do you not want
the american people to know what
happened in the stuart case or any of
these cases chairman durbin i've never
seen
the chairman refuse to allow a witness
to answer a question
you can bang it as loud as you want i
can just tell you at some point you have
to follow the rules okay will you let
her answer the question you've you've
been interrupting and by the way with
senator graham it went 10 minutes over
you've taken a big chunk of the time
will you allow her to answer the
question
you've given her why are you afraid of
her she's welcome to answer it right now
will you let her
senator coons
this is
really masterful stuff here from cruz
you can tell if you didn't already know
it before the guy has stage craft you
can tell that he's argued cases before
the supreme court every time durbin
tries to get the last word to insinuate
dishonestly that cruz doesn't want
katanji jackson to answer the question
cruz cuts back in no you won't let her
answer the question no you won't let her
answer no you won't no you want and it's
back and forth and back and forth and it
sounds like a middle school playground
but cruz is doing it for a reason
after cruz makes a scene and the clip
goes viral there is no mistaking it cruz
wants her to answer the question he
wants to give her time to do that durbin
wants her to keep her mouth shut and
durbin's right to do that because he
knows that katanji jackson's answers on
pedophiles on
life on womanhood they are not going to
play very well in peoria in just three
days katanji jackson has proven herself
to be either the stupidest nominee in
the history of the court or
the most radical
she will be confirmed there is almost no
question about that but she'll be
exposed to
as will every democrat who votes for her
i'm glad you like that cliff now if you
want more clips you've got to
ring the bell
subscribe to the michael knowles show
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your podcasts maybe leave a five star
review and go check out my three-part
docu-series it is blowing up on the
daily wire i think it might be the most
popular
product we've ever put out on the daily
wire for the daily wire audience it's
called fouchy unmasked it's the behind
the scenes true story you've never seen
this before of dr fauci's rise to power
so go check that out we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]